avec nous le dr gilbert bouchet
président de l'association des
spécialistes en médecine d'urgence du
québec également urgentologue à
l'institut de cardiologie de montréal
boston à tabou chez bonjour vous avez un
bon portrait de l'association et dans
les hôpitaux comme urgentologue mais
aussi comme président de l'association
dit nous concrètement comment ça se
passe à ce moment pas très bien en fait
depuis dix jours c'est vraiment
difficile dans les urgences eu un
achalandage à ces monstres ont aussi le
la pandémie on est en pleine sixième
vague ça fait à peu près de 2 3 semaines
pour commence à manquer travailleurs
pour seulement l'urgence mais sur les
états chez que des lits de plus de fermi
on a des patients qui réussissent pas à
sortir des hôpitaux parce qu'on n'a pas
de place pour eux dans les nues
alternatif qui fait les taux
d'occupation sont est très très élevé en
ce moment hier encore le près de 15% des
patients qui sont venus dans nos
urgences sont repartis sans avoir de
médecin alors c'est vraiment pas facile
on le voit pas beaucoup sur la terre on
voit pas quand on bat l'épicerie là mais
je vous dirais que en ce moment dans les
urgences étaient difficiles pas
seulement à cause du coc vide seulement
à cause de toutes les consultations qui
se passe oui c'est ça et vous dites
achalandage monstre bon oui pour la
commune mais l agrée pour si le docteur
boileau qui en parlaient aujourd'hui qui
se met de la partie qu'est ce que ça
vient mettre ça comme pression dans nos
hôpitaux sur le système hospitalier
alors c'est effectivement ces
suppressions de plus on en voit plus
dans la région de québec en ce moment le
chicoutimien aussi sont sous pression
dans la région de montréal c'est un
petit peu un petit peu mélange de tous
faut pas oublier que le coc vide oui
c'est pas des patients très malades mais
ça fait quand même la pression sur le
système les personnes qui sont un petit
peu faible à la maison ronde qui ont
besoin et bike quand on attrape la colle
vide c'est pas des gros problèmes
respiratoires mais il faut souvent les
garder à l'hôpital quelques jours sur ça
prend des ressources monsieur tout le
monde dont on sait la santé mentale
était difficile dans les derniers mois
on le voit sortir les gens ont besoin
mais il ya beaucoup nos salles
d'attentes sont vraiment pas mal on
n'avait pas besoin de ça la grippe qui
qui s'ajoute à tout ça d'autant boucher
est là quand on regarde les chiffres de
la pandémie on franchit à nouveau le cap
des hospitalisations ce qu'on n'avait
pas vu donc depuis des semaines depuis
la mi-février et
dans la conférence de presse aujourd'hui
la docteure boileau a mentionné tous les
outils étaient mises en place à son avis
pour éviter une surcharge du réseau est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui
lui la surcharge du réseau en ce moment
c'est vraiment un ensemble de choses qui
font qu'on a beaucoup de gens l'urgence
c'est vraiment difficile par rapport au
fait que nos salles d'attentes sont
pleines on manque de livres souvent même
un carton dans le personnel et on n'a
pas de classe pour s'occuper des
patients alors oui ça va être important
en fin de ce1 même là on veut les gens
ont besoin de savoir si mais si vous
êtes infecté n'essayez asseyez de rester
un petit peu chez vous dites-vous ce les
gens que vous rencontrez ce que vous
voulez vraiment leur donner ce virus
l'eau est quand même très léger mais
pour les gens qu'ils ont eu lieu surtout
si vous n'êtes pas vacciné ça peut être
quand même assez difficile on parle de
10 jours à la maison sans travail alors
c'est pas des choses faciles mais en ce
moment là je vous dirais depuis deux
jours c'est assez difficile dans nos
urgences si les patients n'ont pas
besoin de venir on vous demande de paume
plus vanter parce que malheureusement on
prend des fois la place des gens qui ont
vraiment besoin des radios est ce que
vous craignez ça quand vous nous parler
des réunions familiales là qui sont
prévues en fin de semaine c'est la
première grosse fête sans directives
vraiment noël puis au jour de l'an il y
en avait des directives est ce que vous
craignez que ça et les impacts
importants dans le réseau dans les
semaines qui vont suivre le dimanche
départ le sait pas nécessairement
seulement par rapport à la commune mais
je vous dirais qu'il ya une
recrudescence de vie depuis 2-3
ça fait quatre semaines que beaucoup de
gastro les centres pédiatriques sont
plaints que ça déborde alors ces souches
sont d'accord ils à yvonne la
contamination sans fin de semaine c'est
sur ce que le personnel on manque de
gens piquante que quelqu'un qui tombe
malade soit confirmée livres soit
quelqu'un qu'il faut qu'ils fassent ont
un double alors c'est vraiment pas
facile par rapport au ratio les gens
faut garder certaine différenciation
mais en ce moment on a comme une
recrudescence pour le juste le colis de
l'homme il ya beaucoup de virus dans
baudot j'ai un peu de tout et finalement
ça se multiplient ont regardé les
chiffres tout à l'heure du personnel
soignant qui est touché près de 13 mai
l'absent dans le réseau est ce qu on
risque de se retrouver dans une autre
situation de d un stage je pense à ceux
qui attendent des chirurgies depuis des
mois voire des années là est ce que vous
pensez qu'on va remonter encore le
niveau délestage en aux hôpitaux
on espère pour nous qu'est ce qu'on voit
depuis trois semaines c'est justement la
vague a commencé le personnel soignant a
été infectée sigean le commence à
revenir déjà fait qu'on espère que ça
montre pas beaucoup plus que treize
mille mais effectivement ça met beaucoup
de pression sur le réseau qui est encore
là on sent lille et on sent les effets
le depuis une semaine près de 60% nous
lis dans les urgences ont pris avec des
patients qui attendent des
hospitalisations qui sait quand on
commence comme en fin de semaine
dernière ça a été très difficile peu
quand on a commencé hier lundi matin on
savait que la semaine allait très très
très difficile plus en ce moment quand
on commence donc hors de travail on
regarde la salle d'attenté on sait qu'on
pourra pas battre toutes les patients
qui ont fait que c'est vraiment
difficile pour la population pour le
moral pour les personnels soignants qui
est en place aussi le devoir dire aux
gens on peut pas vous voir on n'a pas de
place on n'a pas de personnel ben je
vous cacherais pas que à l'inter mieux
certains médecins infirmières ont semble
t'il eu un bris de service parce que on
sait qu'on peut pas donner sur le
discret qui à la population qu'une
triage shadow juste 3 5 minutes alors on
espère pour faire d'erreur mais si c'est
extrêmement difficile le pur pour le
personnel puis comme je vous dis à tout
les jours il y en a qui tombent au
combat cinq jours de sont obligés de
rentrer travailler alors on met l'épaule
à la roue mais mais c'est pas facile nos
salles d'attentes y en a beaucoup
malheureusement l'on nommait mauges
actions qui visent accompagnateurs de
quitter parce que les salles la part de
son trop plein de gens fac c'est pas
facile en ce moment d'ailleurs j'ai
babouche et merci d'avoir été là ça me
donne une bonne idée de l'association ça
nous rappelle à quel point il faut
continuer de faire attention merci de ta
bouche et on voit merci à mme lacroix
barreaux